hi and welcome to game MX is 100 seconds
today we are talking about Oscar Sandra
Bullock's discovery that her husband
Jesse Bullock cheated on her with a
creep on April Fool's April Fool prank
it is March 24th and we talked about
this yesterday yes but the best prank is
the one that you don't cease to expect
more than a week to go now many of you
have probably already read about this
story on the net but for those of you
who haven't been brought up to speed
okay I'm sorry interrupt but I just
bought these guy regular cookies for you
and I thought you might like them so
when you gave me that tin of cookies
yesterday it was full of pot full of
hands yesterday hero fools pullup ends
today now we don't know much about
michelle bombshell mcgee but i hadn't
either say i feel bad i did make you
could I approvals april fools more pens
perhaps the saddest thing about the news
so quickly it's not even a price
keeps putting garbage my face when I'm
trying to talk game what maybe you
wouldn't be as intense if you just had a
sip of this martini so glad you soapy
water with a cigarette it just stop stop
it don't you need to stop all right I'm
sorry so in conclusion the real question
I guess is we'll Sandra Bullock take her
cheating husband Jesse James back I
think that's the question a lot of
people are asking themselves you know
speaking from personal experience when
the trust in a relationship is broken
like this it can just be so hard to get
it back maybe even in pot is he standing
behind me he's named I me the old
standing behind you right